We should start bringing it to other people too.
Occasionally.
Especially when a accounts out of town cause counts.
Always busy.
Yeah,
but he brings a cheese then nothing's like the four of us though.
The chemistry with the finance.
You can't,
you can't fuck with it.
No.
It is the best and it's the most fun by far is the most fun to watch.
Fight a different dynamic.
Yeah,
but the talking over my God,
I tried to listen to it.
You did.
I tried to listen to someone.
What you do,
cause I want to know what it sounded like.
We were talking over everybody.
It's terrible.
Drunk and high and a long time and it was awesome.
People for whatever reason,
love those kind of chaos shows like that Alex Jones show.
They'll love chaos.
They'll love it.
They'll love a struck and stoned and an interdimensional child molesters and
fucking,
they love all that shit.
They love it off the charts.
Nuts that Alex Jones one though I told you I've never been a fan of his.
Then I watch it.
I'm like got to like them now.
People are mad at me.
For.
Some people are mad at me,
but you know,
there's nothing I could do about that.
There were going to be mad at me anyway.
But one of the things that they were saying was,
you know,
fuck you for uh,
there were saying giving them a platform for normalizing him and like you got to
understand,
that's how I know him.
I know him like that.
That's how I know him.
I know that guy,
that guy friends.
Yes.
That guy that came on here,
and this is a guy that by the way on his show said he was gonna kick my ass and
break my legs and fucking all kinds of crazy shit and I want to find him in the
UFC fight.
I'm to offer him $1 million.
Like I knew I knew him.
I know the real him.
I'm like,
well,
we're not in front of each other.
You could say crazy shit.
And like I'm immune man.
I don't,
I don't care.
It doesn't bother me.
I don't care anymore.
He's doing an entertainment show.
He is doing entertainment but,
but when I know is the Alex Jones,
those here,
and by the way,
he was right about a lot of shit while the crazy shit that he's saying about
the,
about fucking human pig hybrids that they're working on those and actually
making human pig hybrid fetuses.
That's real.
They really aren't.
The problem is is he throws so much shit out there at all at one time.
I don't know what to believe in what exactly.
And you got to slow down to look into all of that and you got to go slow.
Whoa,
whoa.
Let's take start.
Start over again.
W what?
What's happening on the moon?
He's for sure a little crazy.
I like him but he's,
he's crazy.
But I think the crazy is okay and it's entertaining and I'm not a fucking child.
So if you want a nerf the world and make the world so that only children can
watch everybody cause like make,
make things at their own that are safe for everyone,
including children.
Well,
I don't want that.
I want,
I'm a discerning adults.
I'm pretty rational and I can figure out what's real and what's nonsense.